is it necessary to Vlog with a fancy
DSLR or is this something you can do
with your iPhone today's dailyvee we're
going to take you along with Gary on all
the interviews he did at the radio row
Super Bowl event in Phoenix Arizona and
show comparison footage between the
iPhone 14 Promax versus a Sony a7c
you'll see some of the pros and cons as
you follow along so let's get into it
killing me radio bro
like always
so you obviously are working with young
athletes what's the biggest Financial
mistake you see them make early on in
their careers buying dumb crap a car
they shouldn't buy jewelry they
shouldn't buy just cliche stuff look I
think everyone needs a level of outlet
and enjoyment but I think for some kids
they get too crazy on that and then the
reverse the players are getting smarter
I think too many kids make investments
in companies because macro it sounds
right but a lot of times 95 of those
companies are going to zero so what is
the smartest thing you think they can do
is live within your means which means
have some savings out of that so if it's
400 000 take home after taxes don't live
a four hundred thousand dollar life live
a 250 000 life so you have a hundred
fifty thousand dollars in savings so I
think living within your means is always
the game in addition to being an
entrepreneur you're also a big investor
yes what do you look for you get pitched
up all the time every day all day jockey
and horse the business is the horse do I
like the business but without the CEO if
she or he can't ride that horse it's not
going to matter anyway do I think
bananas being delivered to your home on
a one hour notice is that a good
business in that scenario I'm like no
I'm not that interested no matter if
Jeff Bezos is running it but that
quarterback that CEO is a humongous
variable and I look for that
there's some people that just have no
conscience it's crazy I would actually
argue that it's the complete reverse of
that it's not that they don't have
conscious it's that they're actually
hurting
ah seriously what does that hurt people
hurt people isn't that a thing oh is
that real it's the it's actually the
realest [__] statement how do you
change that oh yeah by having compassion
and empathy for people that are hurting
[Music]
quite well Schmo thank you message for
all the Gary fee fans out there
worldwide just one life you live one
actual life are you gonna actually live
it for everyone's opinions on the
Internet or you're gonna live it for
yourself
Pro on the Schmo Super Bowl radio as
well we're out
and do it thank you
[Music]
thank you
is what do you tell these younger kids
who have such a crappy outlook on things
hard work's not paying off they're not
motivated they're not seeing the likes
that they want to see on social media
how do you keep these kids
you know I think truth really just works
like when they're like we don't have it
as good as our parents generation I'm
like no no don't read a headline tell me
about you right I don't want to know
about gen Z or Boomers or Millennials or
Gen X tell me about you and all of a
sudden it becomes a game of
accountability if you decide that you
saw two tick tocks and they say that gen
Z doesn't have it as good as their
parents had it and you just believe that
well it's a wrap if you also realize
that there's unlimited kids on Tick Tock
right now making more money and are
happier than their parents were you're
all of a sudden like saying wait it is
possible so to me what do I tell the
kids to stop talking in generalization
and start talking about themselves and
start focusing on what they're gonna do
about it just
the day on the strongest Road Five
Barrels to the six it's a long way home
stay moving with a purpose got a feeling
my cup is head heavy with the crown but
it caused my soul I'm the master of my
[__] my navigation legit I have to get
something off my chest I have a little
shopping problem okay I like to buy
stuff I like to buy clothes jewelry how
can I spend my money the right way first
we need to find out why do you like it I
like Swag like I'm swaggy you know I got
the drip on so yeah but you got such a
swaggy face you don't need all those
things
you're welcome I look I think it's more
than okay to buy nice things it's not
okay to buy nice things when you can't
afford them
so the biggest thing you need to think
about is living within your means you
guys are working hard and making some
paper you can buy some stuff but don't
spend all of it on those kind of things
put some stuff away for savings but you
can enjoy yourself within your means I
love to
love it
well good just spend 35 of it and say it
save the other 25.
Garrett here you're buying the Jets that
when's that happening we're working on
it every day every day
I work hard every day it's a big goal of
mine I would love to achieve it I'm also
incredibly comfortable if I don't but
I'd like to try have you spoken to the
Johnson family at all no because I think
that's disrespectful to be honest with
you mark like if I'm not in a position
to buy it that's just hubris that's just
delusional that's just a a little
egotistical I don't want to waste
people's time they've got plenty of
things to do running their team and
their family fund and all that so not
yet
what practical advice do you have for
people who want to see the next thing
being a yes person versus a no person
let me explain the next big thing is
obvious to a lot of people here it's
called chat GPT artificial intelligence
do you know how many people mags in this
entire hall right now dismisses as bad
oh it's gonna take people's jobs away so
is the tractor we were all doing farm
jobs and then the tractor was invented
and that took people's jobs away they
found different jobs most people are no
people no to tick tock no to chat you
people no to VR they feed her new things
no no no what about streaming services
in Hollywood yeah people just say no no
no no no no no when the world is always
yes yes yes yes that's my answer to the
question
I told one of my friends the other day
that I love them I don't think I've ever
told him that I told him I was proud of
him like I'm getting Goosebumps because
we need more of that bro we need more of
that saying that to people it matters
and I think we should be giving way more
roses to each other instead of pointing
fingers and trying to tear down each
other and I will pump that until I can't
breathe all day all day
[Music]
this weekend and what's going to be the
moment a genuine Connection getting into
an actual conversation with somebody
that's what I'm looking for
it's always been the most widely watched
event of the year but compared to the
single audience of any other program
show any place you could find people
assembled it's that much bigger on an on
a relative basis does that actually
translate directly into return on
investment no it doesn't it's that
Americans actually want to watch the
commercials nobody wants to watch the
commercials on the Grammys nobody wants
to watch the commercials on the Oscars
nobody wants to watch the commercials in
the AFC and NFC Championship Game this
is the only time people in America
actually want to watch a commercial thus
rendering it the best deal while all the
other commercials on television are
grossly overpriced
awesome it was a really good hit
unbelievable yeah it was great there's a
lot of different versions of me
that's like businessman version of me
you know and he did the sports thing
yeah I'll do slime and Nicola you know
it's just this was a good day it was a
good day we're productive last time on
dailyvee leave a question in the
comments so that I can answer it on the
next dailyvee I'm on my way to the
bathroom and Dustin's doing a good job
to get me on the Vlog what's up team
hi hi good to see you
okay is the music gonna be a problem
with like YouTube like Creative Commons
yeah we'll keep all this go ahead do you
get frustrated yep does not go your way
no always have a plan B I have a plan C
D E F this is not the whole plan a if
you have don't have a if you don't have
a plan B you get the plan a I'm talking
about like in the day-to-day like I have
a macro plan a of like being the best
most positive entrepreneur I can be
that's I won't compromise but day to day
as we like live life and like navigate
and operate businesses you can walk by
yeah you guys are fine we keep it very
raw around here go ahead go ahead we're
good have the best day guys
um you're gonna have to hire this is
tall
um take care there's nothing goes the
way I want it's only adjusting to the
micro plan B's the micro plan Seas the
micro plan D's macro there's only a plan
A day-to-day every plan gets [__] up I
don't know a single thing I've done in
the last 10 years that's gotten the way
I thought it does
we're always count we're like it's like
boxing you have a game plan going into
the ring but like if you're not
adjusting to what's happening they
didn't get knocked the [__] out
I'm not trying to get knocked the [__]
out
yeah
thanks